hello everyone and welcome back to the
quarterfinals of the opera euro rapid uh
we are going to show the absolutely best
game of yesterday uh lebanon versus
maxine vasher lagrave this is their
second game of the match
and it features uh quite a quite a
deadly groomfield game and i know what
you're thinking oh come on you're not
going to show another game
where maxime just loses in the
groomfield uh could be but then again uh
you know anything else could happen as
well uh so uh without further ado let's
check it out as uh
it's quite the beauty so uh 11
with the white pieces opens with d4 uh
we have knight to f6 by maxim
c4 uh we have g6 and now knight to c3
and like we said we are going into the
groomfield defense so d5
knight to f3 and now bishop to g7 and
usually i think the
the last um maybe four or five times
that we've shown this variation we
always go into the same characters
captures e4 and then the trade here
where white gets this very strong center
uh this is sort of the well the most
usual way to play this but here
11 goes for queen to b3 it's the
so-called russian variation
and i have no idea why it's called that
i imagine some very strong russians play
that if you have any
insight on this do share it in the
comments i will up in your comment for
everyone else to see
uh but it puts additional pressure to
the center here
which black definitely uses he wants to
bring the queen closer to the center
captures captures makes white lose a
tempo and now
uh castles is what's usually played here
but bishop to e6 is becoming
uh increasingly popular so here uh we
have queen to a4 with
check bishop goes back to block the
check and now queen to b3 so the queen
again retreats the queen
to b3 going after the b7 pawn and now c5
this is all still
very uh very theoretic theoretical as
the b7 pawn is not free for grabs
i will show what happens if you grab it
if you grab it it's just game over
knight to c6 and now you are in in in
big big trouble
so uh rook to b8 is coming and if you
try to prevent that you you have to
start running away with the queen or
even bishop to f4
guarding that square but now c captures
on d4
attacks the knight and after knight to
b5 now you are threatening knight c7
check
now comes just uh castles and after
something like bishop to c7 attacking
the queen queen to c8 and once the
queens get traded off captures captures
is just a
much much better position for for black
it's a winning position for black
you cannot move the knight the bishop is
hanging and once you retreat
the bishop now comes knight to e4 and
black has
all of its pieces developed uh uh the
the the white king is still on e1 and
there's simply too many threats to
uh to even play this uh so here after
the c5 move of course 11 doesn't go for
the b7 pawn
he pushes d5 and now comes b5 so this is
all still
uh ver very much known c4 is coming and
this is basically upon sacrifice uh
white can capture this but then black
will get a lot of very interesting uh
counterplay so knight captures on b5
and now what's usually played here and
what is known until this game happened
is queen to a5
check and with queen to a5 check just
everything gets traded off knight to c3
knight captures on d5 giving up the
knight for bishop captures on c3 and
after this happens the queen captures
bishop captures on c3 with
check uh bishop to d2 we're gonna play
bishop to c6
uh attack the white queen because our
rook is hanging and after bishop
captures on c3 attacking black's queen
we have queen captures b
captures and bishop captures on d5 and
we go into this end game with absolutely
equal material
pretty much the same pawn structure so
everything is perfectly fine for both
sides
so this is how this position was played
so far but here maxine plays
knight to a6 and it is as of move 10
that we have a completely new game and
this is uh
really fascinating because uh to this
day i have not
witnessed a game where maxine plays the
groomfield without placing this knight
on a6 i dare you to find such a game
so knight to a6 basically a signature
mcc move
and now now we have a completely new
game so 11 needs to figure out
what to do here he goes back with the
knight rook to b8 is coming that's for
sure so knight back to c3
rook to b8 and the queen to d1 so going
back and queen to a5 and look at all
this uh
beautiful development that maxime got
for the price of one pawn the bishop
slices over here queen slices over here
knight ready to jump here you're
hindering the development of uh
blacks uh oh for whites the dark square
bishop as the b two pawn is under attack
the bishop can very easily come into
play
as the knight is pinned so this is just
uh uh this is so good i might even
consider
uh you know maybe even learning a thing
or two about about
this line uh so here we have queen to d2
and queen to d2 is probably where maxime
uh caught 11 off guard it seems uh
uh difficult for whites to find the move
here
but but bishop to d2 is the way to go
you give up the pawn here and after the
rook captures the pawn then you go rook
to c1
add an additional defender and then
you're going to go e for develop the
bishop and castle king side
however after this queen the a511 tries
to keep everything intact
uh as he has won some material so he's
going to try and keep it all in check
but now knight to b4 and now what do you
play here
bishop to a4 is coming knight to c2
check is coming a3 does nothing because
the rook here on a1 is undefended
so here e4 by 11 he only needs two more
moves to get his king to safety and then
he just has a better position
but bishop to a4 now threatening knight
to c2 with check
and the problem is bishop to d3 doesn't
work yes you guard this but after knight
captures and queen captures
we again get this knight captures on e4
and this is basically the theme of this
game that this bishop once unleashed
will simply wreak havoc along white's
queen side
so queen capture sunny e4 bishop
captures on c3 with check you can't
capture because queen capture so king f1
and now rook to b4 is just a
a terrifying position for for white to
play it's very unlikely that white can
survive this
so after bishop to a4 we have b3 a
necessary evil
and now bishop captures on b3 of course
the rook is undefended
uh but this is probably the best way to
go for maxim uh for 11. and with bishop
to c4 he kind of consolidates here he's
going to castle to safety and maybe he
can continue playing this
but lemon again tries to keep everything
intact plays rook to b1
and now comes bishop the c2 chasing away
the rook and now there really
isn't a a square available for this rook
if you go rook back to a1
you again face this knight captures an
e4 idea and after knight captures
bishop captures then the rook is once
again attacked by the bishop and
with this bishop covering b1 there is no
saving this rook and as you can see the
bishop pair is is definitely fully
operational
so after bishop c2 we have rook to b3
uh not much not much you can play here
and now just bishop captures on b3
a captures and now knight to d7 maxim
now wants to get this bishop into the
attack but also a very interesting idea
is knight
g for trying to get the bishop into the
the attack this way as the knight now
covers the h6 square
but okay knight to d7 uh we have bishop
to b2
now adding another defender to the
knight and here uh maxime finally
castles
uh we have bishop to e2 and now comes
knight to a2 with a triple attack on the
knight interestingly knight to d3 check
is also possible i'm just going to show
it
to show you how rich this line is
because after bishop captures of course
now you go for rook captures on b3 and
again there's a triple attack on this
knight now and if you move the knight to
try and trade the queens off
queen captures you're going to play
knight captures and now you just play
rook captures on d3 that's the idea and
after captures and captures
you up the exchange you're up upon you
have to pass pawns you are completely
winning here
but okay it's a rapid game of course
players don't have all the time in the
world
so knights to a2 uh and now comes
knight to a4 here uh 11 thought okay
now now i have unites the a4 i'm
offering a queen trade
i'm offering the trade of bishops i'm
gonna get my king into the center of the
board my
rook will be able to come into the game
i'm maybe surviving this
but there is one move that uh well
completely shatters all of white's hopes
so feel free to pause the video and try
to find this idea for maxime while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to find
it congratulations and always uh looking
in the absolute uh correct place and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's queen capture sun a4
yes a beautiful queen sacrifice and now
there is
nothing more for uh white to be done
here
uh the absolute strongest is just
accepting the queen but it's
insufficient if the queen is accepted
then we get rook captures on b2
attacking the queen and now
bishop to c3 is coming and this is just
terrible once you move the queen
bishop to c3 check and now if king f1
then rook to d1
it's game over and if knights to d2 it's
giving up even more material but you
know there's not much you can do
bishop captures uh if the king moves
rook to b1 again
game over so you have to capture the
bishop and after captures captures
you just have a much much better
position uh you're up uh you're up a
piece and it's uh
it's not even close for white to even
try this so although this is the best
move uh by the engine it's not enough so
11 has to try something else 11 finds
bishop captures on g7
but now rook captures on b3
threatening rook to b1 check so what do
you play here
uh well not much to be done here if
castle's king captures here black is
just of material
and uh if bishop captures an f8 what was
played in the game
again rook to b1 check 11 has to try and
survive this somehow
bishop to d1 now queen captures an e4
with
check king f1 and now knight the c3 a
beautiful
move as now the bishop is attacked twice
there's no defending this uh 11 simply
has to pick up the knight
so queen captures now rook captures and
d1 with
check knight to e1 blocking and only now
only now
knight captures on f8 and here you can
see that 11 is still kind of
hanging on its own maximum is only up
one pawn but it's uh
it's such a disgusting position for
white that
it's it's hard to say if it's even
possible to continue this but 11 always
finds a way
h4 now the rook is coming into the game
and
well good things might happen so queen
captures on d5
grabbing yet another pawn and now rook
to h3
we have knights to e6 now maximum of
course wants the knights to join the
attack
rook to e3 and now comes rook to d4
cutting the king's uh uh access to this
diagonal
at some point you might uh you might
have to worry about moves like h5 h6
because if h5 you don't want to capture
rook g3 check is coming
so it it definitely makes sense uh so
here we have knight to f3
attacking the rook and defending the h4
pawn
but now comes just queen to c for check
now maxime
being up so much material is very
confident in being able to win this end
game
uh although even rogue d1 check is
sufficient rookie one just c4 you
improve the position a little bit and
you can always trade but no point in
giving 11
any chance is best just to uh go queen
to c for
check uh we have queen captures and c
for rook captures and now rook to a3
going after the a7 pawn but maxime is up
too much material
knight to d4 uh threatening knight
captures the
completely shattered white's king side
knight captures with
c captures now getting another pass pawn
here and
rook captures on a7 uh we have d3 taking
away the e2 square from the white king
rook c1 is the threat
of checkmate here so king he won and now
rook to e4 with check again if king goes
back you can just start pushing the pawn
so king d2 but now maxine just
wins everything on the on the king's
side rook to e to check king captures on
the e3
and rook captures on f2 and now with uh
white uh white uh probably gonna gonna
lose all of those pawns and black still
having four of them
uh there's nothing really you can do
here it was in this position on move 38
that uh 11 uh resigned to the game and a
wonderful
victory for maxine who after got a win
in the second game uh they drew third
and fourth and maxine is the winner of
the first match so here
uh you can simply okay you can capture
on e7 uh but then just rook captures on
g2 and europe two points of course both
of them can
win this blindfold for black so of
course eleven uh will not even uh
attempt a defense here and he was
extremely low on time i think he had
like a few seconds whereas maxim had i
think some five minutes but um
i mean what a game uh what what a game
and i think
i think i enjoyed this so much that uh
you know it kind of you know when you
see a game and you see what
what an opening can do that you
immediately get this urge to study chess
openings uh so i might do i might do a
quick tutorial on this line for black as
it's uh
very interesting but i don't know i
don't know if it's worth it as queen to
b3
i don't know how often you guys even
encounter this in your online games
but it is uh it is a very interesting
way of
of countering this russian variation of
the groomfield
uh so yeah uh that's it hope you guys
enjoyed it really really amazing stuff
uh i would like to thank
veto nasimi russell lloyd gordon goodman
enrique salami and
um and narasimhan uh ragaman for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the opera euro rapid
elimination uh games checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day